como você começou com a luta eu tinha um
problema assim de ombro e um outro de
fígado que era do fígado era da gordura
do fígado que tava muito alto e um do
meu ombro que o meu ombro quando eu era
criança assim eu fui empurrar um carro
com meu meu pai minha família tava meio
chovendo o carro tava deslizando e eu
empurrando o carro meu hbro saiu assim
foi a primeira vez que eu senti meu
hombro sair desde então ele sai direto
direto tô jogando basquete vou pegar a
bola ele sai eu tô nadando Tô dando uma
abraçada aqui ele sai do lugar de novo
aí o médico falou para mim que
eu pegasse algum Esporte que
fortalecesse mais os ombros e o box é um
um um que fortalece os ombros né só que
eu não consigo fazer as coisas assim
pela metade não eu gosto de fazer tudo
no meu 100% mesmo assim até eu me
arrebentar mesmo assim eu acho que aí
quando eu me arrebento aí eu falo assim
EA garotão você não é o Superman não
relaxa